I expected a hard fight you know I put
my family through a lot
you get it the harder you fight I get it
let's go only now it's taking way too
many hits before you get off you can't
fight like that anymore think about her
the light heavyweight champion I won't
be here without my wife Marie really
what do you mean this old man keep
walking babe you ain't never been with a
real man let's go home well I take your
belt
this Court is aware of the tragedy your
family has suffered mr. hope
nonetheless you have chosen to
demonstrate dangerous behaviors while
having custody of your daughter
you need help it'll be a year before
your suspension is up which means zero
income legal custody of the child shall
remain with Family Services until the
father can demonstrate the abilities of
a responsible parent
you wanna come with no I got do this
alone so a breeze Billy hope
imagine I'm looking for a job maybe
place a train you couldn't handle the
rosehip I can't lose my daughter I'll
give you my everything I know that
you're mad at me right now you don't
know anything she doesn't want to see
you today
I love me got a letter H so she can get
better I just have to fight at that time
you think that you could beat miss no
without you fight again when I get my
kid back what chance is there that hope
could win because the stick against hope
people can make this shitake showroom
you control your destiny